[Music]
14 has turned Pauly D into a new man
literally like you won't even recognize
him the Jersey Shore star has fans
totally swooning over his new look which
includes a quote quarantine beard yeah
that's Pauly
the reality star shared the clip on
Instagram Monday alongside the caption
new flex no but seriously what and his
Jersey Shore co-star Mike the situation
Sorrentino appears to be a fan of the
makeover commenting quote beard gang and
Mike he's not the only fan the thirst is
real one fan commented that his beard is
like magic
while another wrote you're telling me
you could have had this beard the whole
time you better keep it Pauly even
covered up his trademark blowout with a
Yankees hat and the lack of hair gel has
me totally should it's very moving my
dude 150 miles an hour on the highway on
a street bike doesn't move but don't
worry guys he hasn't gotten rid of his
signature due yet over the weekend he
shared this clip that showed his
gel-filled locks fully intact but he did
kinda sorta hints that he's thinking
about changing it up when one follower
wrote I think it's time for a new
hairstyle he responded well said and
brace yourself guys because Pauly
recently shared a clip of his hair sans
hair product I think I'm losing my mind
which he captioned no gel who did know
but seriously who dis has held frozen
over Pauly first debuted his quarantined
beard on Instagram in April to rave
reviews and he's been keeping fans
updated on its growth ever since yo B is
coming in
quite nicely he captioned that post
quote hi I have a beard yes yes you do
and for all those ladies looking for a
shot with a newly bearded DJ good luck
I find love every single day but I fall
out every single morning on June 11th
will see the season 2 premiere of double
shot at love with DJ Pauly D and Vinny
where the guys try to find romance in
Sin City
with their exes from season 1 wild
[Applause]
Pauly you as a 7 year old daughter
Amma Bella told ET in 2018 that he's
extra particular about who he brings
home these days now I'm even more picky
when I pick women to actually meet her
oh my mother like only the certain ones
will meet them that's why I like I put
my standards up higher a lot higher now
is dating hard having a daughter well
it's just hard in general now because
you got to question their motives and
intentions it's hard dating and generous
why I'm single so he's supposed to look
first supposed to just come I'm hoping
the happy
[Music]